governor brainerd thank you so much for
joining us it's a pleasure to have you
with us today
well thank you it's a pleasure to join
you for this conversation
and thank you to all of those who are
joining us live on twitter and youtube
governor brainerd let's get into it this
morning the labor department said the
consumer prices rose
1.2 percent in march to a year over to a
year-over-year rate of eight and a half
percent a new four-decade high core
prices excluding food and energy were
somewhat less boomy rising three-tenths
of a percentage point
was there any takeaway for you from this
report does it change your outlook or
your preferred path for policy in the
coming months
yeah i think there are two developments
in the cpi inflation data uh for march
uh that were notable uh
the commodities price shock associated
with russia's invasion of ukraine is
driving that very high top line
inflation number you see and in
particular in
today's cpi reading energy prices
accounted for nearly 70 percent of the
monthly headline reading particularly
gasoline prices at the pump and food
contributed another 10
those price increases are particularly
painful
for lower income families who spend a
larger share of their income on food and
transportation
the cpi data also showed a notable
slowdown in core inflation
it fell from
0.5 month over month the last few months
to 0.3
in the latest print and core inflation
is the component of inflation that that
most closely reflects the strength of
domestic demand and i'm
most focused on for purposes of
assessing the appropriate catholic
monetary policy
and then looking within that i think
it's notable that poor goods which which
has been the source of an outsized
amount of core inflationary pressure
moderated more than expecting
more than than i had anticipated so if
you look in in terms of the overall core
cpi
um the prices in core goods have been
responsible for almost half of the
increase in core inflation over the past
year
even though they normally account for
only about a quarter of the overall so
it's very welcome to see the moderation
as category
and i'll be looking to see whether we
continue to see
uh moderation in the months ahead
we did see some upward pressure in
course services and in particular uh in
energy price sensitive uh airfares but
there was some moderation in rent which
is also notable
i wouldn't take a lot of signal from any
one month of data but i will be watching
carefully for a continuation of this
kind of pattern with moderating poor
inflation and a declining number of
categories seeing outsized price
increases in the months ahead and as
we've said
inflation is too high and getting
inflation down is going to be our most
important task
well thanks governor brainerd since this
is the wsj's job summit i'll talk a
little bit about or i'll ask you a
little bit about the labor market
and might come back to inflation in a
minute you gave a speech last fall
talking about the prospect for a durable
recovery in labor participation or the
number of people who are either working
or looking for work and on one hand
more workers
looking for jobs might take some of the
boil off of wage growth that we've seen
on the other hand it's possible i guess
the increase in overall incomes as more
people
come into the job market could keep
demand elevated so how has your outlook
for the labor market changed over the
last six months
yeah so i think what we've seen
in the labor market and the economy
overall
is very strong demand
demand that has been
particularly concentrated in
durable goods um
relative to services and that is also i
think uh reflective of
the pandemic and then labor supply
that has been
slow to respond to that really strong
labor demand
for reasons that appear to be
quite clearly related to the pandemic
and you see that in the surveys whether
it's been
care giving constraints
or fears of the virus that have been
keeping
people from returning to the labor force
so right now we're seeing a historically
high level of job openings which
reflects that the demand for workers is
well above
the current supply
but what has been very encouraging in
the last
few months of the employment reports
um is uh that we are seeing um a
rebound in participation
it's it's normal for labor force
participation to recover more slowly
than unemployment declines in most
recoveries but this cycle it's been
particularly acute again because of
pandemic constraints
so as we see
in the last
two months of employment data you had
primage labor force participation
um jumping uh for women um in the most
recent and for uh men
uh in uh the report prior to that but
the share of the population that's
employed is still about one percentage
point below its pre-coded level and
participation rates are also still down
because there's room to run there um and
more broadly i expect demand to moderate
uh fiscal uh is going to be a drag this
year uh financial conditions are
tightening we're going to get some
um spillover from slower growth abroad
and so
you know i do expect those supply
constraints to lift at the same time as
we see
demand moderating and that's why
we can expect to see the recovery
sustained even as we bring inflation
down
in the fed's most recent projections at
your march meeting
many of your colleagues saw the
unemployment rate holding at three and a
half percent near current low levels
over the next few years
that's below the four percent level that
you or your colleagues estimate as
likely to uh materialize over the long
run
those projections also saw inflation
coming down to two percent over the next
few years even though interest rates
don't rise very much above two percent
now larry summers said recently
that this is an example of wishful and
delusional thinking and and so i wonder
how is it that you can have inflation
coming down closer to two percent with
the labor market staying
possibly quite tight
yeah so um i think the um
the
um
forward uh
trajectory of demand um
is set to moderate um
and uh that's for a number of reasons uh
again just going through them really
quickly fiscal support
is a substantial drag this year
um
financial conditions are already
tightening and when we think about um
what affects
business investment household durable
goods
purchases it's really those broader
financial conditions facing uh
businesses and households and we've
already seen a nearly two percentage
point increase for instance in mortgages
so
those financial conditions will also
bring demand to a more sustainable level
and we also should see some rotation of
demand as uh
pandemic constraints uh continue to lift
we should see uh some return to historic
patterns of greater relative demand for
services and less pressure in that
supply constrained durable goods sector
and of course as we were just discussing
on the supply side i'd expect to see um
continued uh improvements in labor force
participation
so as we continue to
move forward on our plan um to move
um the uh uh financial conditions to
more neutral levels using both our
policy
uh rate and uh balance sheet tools you
know i'd expect to see labor demand uh
coming down and that should take place
um in large measure um through reduction
in the current very elevated uh level of
vacancies so you know i think there's
plenty of room um for businesses to
reduce the job uh the number of job
openings um and so i don't see
that
as we
go forward on this path of moving
monetary policy to more neutral level i
really see that as being consistent with
both bringing inflation down and
sustaining the recovery
two big developments so far this year of
course have been russia's invasion of
ukraine
you referred to this last week as a
seismic geopolitical event and then also
we're seeing some pretty sharp lockdowns
again in china
how do those two developments change the
outlook you have for inflation uh this
year and and perhaps next year
yeah so um russia's invasion of ukraine
is as you said it's a seismic
geopolitical event it's a human tragedy
but it is also
a very um important contributor to
inflationary pressures
in particular we're already seeing it
through commodities prices we talked
about
this morning's really large increase in
prices at the pump that's uh that really
reflects the russia shock
and it probably skews risks to the
upside in inflation and to the downside
on economic activity particularly abroad
but that can have some implications here
so we've already seen um prices of
energy and other commodities moving up
we've seen that in nickel for instance
we're seeing it
in
other areas like fertilizer um and of
course we've seen uh the price of brent
crude moving up by about 12 on net since
the invasion
um
and you know there are also likely to be
um some knock-on effects for global
supply chains as europe for instance
takes on board
this large shock to natural gas prices
that can be expected to both
affect demand uh and supply and and that
can have some knock-on effects here
um the longer the conflict persists the
more it escalates the greater the
potential
uh risks again uh to the upside on
inflation into the downside on activity
you also mentioned china you know china
is uh right now um
continuing its um zero covid lockdown
policy
seems to be having a notable effect on
activity
it certainly has
the potential
to
lengthen out some of those constraints
that we've seen in supply chains
we've certainly seen
with the previous surges uh that they've
led to port shutdowns in china they've
led to indeed uh increased uh chip
delays and so there too this is just as
uh
another set of inflationary shocks and
of course you know the economy has um
sustained now uh a number of these kinds
of inflationary shock from
external events uh whether it be
pandemic now russia ukraine lockdowns in
china
we've seen a lot of resilience but we've
also seen very high inflation
you spoke in a speech last september
about good reasons
to expect a return to pre-covet
inflation dynamics you cited underlying
structural features of a relatively flat
phillips curve
where lower unemployment rates don't
necessarily push prices up all that much
low equilibrium interest rates
low underlying trend inflation is that
still your base case scenario
for once we get through this period
yeah so i think
it is uh too early
to have great confidence
in
what the post-pandemic
post-russia ukraine
contours of the new normal are likely to
be
um
in terms of
the
level of the real
long-run
neutral rate of interest
the rate of interest that economists
think of as being consistent with full
employment and low stable inflation you
know there are good reasons to think
that will uh continue to be uh at levels
uh that are quite low relative to the
historical experience
um but again you know i i think we uh
need to see
how the economy evolves clearly we've
experienced a series of very large
inflationary shocks
and the committee is committed to
bringing inflation back to our two
percent gold
um and our framework is very focused on
um
the uh keeping uh inflation expectations
anchored at two percent uh so i think um
there we can anticipate
um that uh inflation will also
return um to those levels uh over time
um and of course we have a labor market
um
that over a longer period of time has
proven to be quite elastic but in the
short
run um has been very uh affected by
covet
um and so it'll take more time
than i think anybody would have
anticipated uh to be able to assess
those contours of the new normal
you spoke last week in a speech about
moving
policy settings expeditiously to be
closer to a neutral interest rate and
you spoke a little while ago about uh
getting financial conditions to a more
neutral level
where
is right now or maybe by the end of this
year where might a neutral interest rate
or a neutral rate setting when combined
with
the runoff of the fed's asset portfolio
where might that be around the end of
this year where is a neutral rate in
your view
yeah so it's a good question the neutral
rate is a longer run concept
as i noted earlier it's the level of
interest rate that's neither
expansionary uh nor contractionary when
the economy is at full employment with
stable inflation
um
in terms of um
where
the policy rate is likely to be heading
over time i'd say both
the last
projections that we had from the
committee as well as the minutes
and market pricing the median
funds rate path does rise over the
course of this year
and we've indicated that it's likely
we'll begin we will
will decide as soon as may
to start reducing the size of the
balance sheet in which case those
reductions could uh come as soon as june
and the combination of policy actions
along these lines
should bring the overall policy stance
to a more neutral setting over time but
it's important to note that i don't look
at
one number
and i certainly don't just look at the
policy rate because it's the combined
impact
of our balance sheet
and the policy rate on financial
conditions so when i look at financial
conditions i'm really looking at the
kinds of
conditions that are facing businesses
and households as they decide whether to
make investments um and there i think
the communications about our policy
plans have already been tightening those
broader financial conditions over the
past you know really uh four to five
months considerably more than you might
be able to discern from just looking at
the policy rate alone so if you look at
um over the calendar year of 2022 market
implied policy rate expectations for the
end of this year have risen quite a lot
policy sensitive rates have risen by
similar amounts so we've seen the
two-year nominal yield going up by a
considerable amount relative to early or
this year or the end of last year
and five and 10-year treasury yields are
about 140 and 120 basis points higher um
and so those are all reflecting
communication um and as i think i might
have mentioned um
if you look at the 30-year fixed rate
mortgage it's almost two percentage
points higher uh year-to-date as a
result of expectations about our policy
path and again the combination of the
balance sheet with um increases in the
policy rate
there certainly have been uh more
aggressive expectations built into
financial markets because of the change
in the fed's communications it's of
course not just the one rate increase
but as you sit here today
uh thinking about where the where the
economy is
uh if the goal is to get interest rates
closer to neutral more quickly this year
does that mean that you're prepared to
support raising rates in half percentage
point increments at the next
at the next fed meeting or even at the
next two fed meetings
well i would say um that in terms of
the communication from the committee
um
uh you saw uh that um
we've said for instance um in the in the
most recent minutes that the committee
expects to move the stance of monetary
policy
toward a neutral posture expeditiously
and we are
committed to bringing inflation back
down to two percent
we're doing that by tightening monetary
policy methodically and it's through a
series of interest rate increases
as well as
beginning that balance sheet runoff with
a decision coming
could be
as soon as may
which would lead to reductions in that
balance sheet
starting in june
in terms of exactly what the right piece
of
that
set of
increases in the policy rate from
meeting to meeting i i don't um really
want to focus on that but i would just
say the combined effect
will bring um the policy stance uh to
more neutral posture
expeditiously um later this year
because it takes time for monetary
policy to influence the economy uh we
hear right now economists talking a lot
about a soft landing where the fed is
able to raise interest rates to moderate
the pace of growth but avoiding a
recession of course achieving a soft
landing implies that the fed will stop
raising interest rates before it's too
late so i wonder do you see any stopping
rule or maybe even a slowing rule
that would guide your thinking
about when a slowdown or even a pause in
removing policy accommodation would be
appropriate
yeah so it's um
a good question um i don't i don't have
a stopping rule per se um this is a very
unusual
recovery
uh it's just been made
more complicated as if the pandemic was
not complicated enough
by russia's invasion of ukraine um so i
don't uh i don't want to be
too
uh rigid in how i think about the
appropriate course of policy
over the remainder of this year and into
next year
i do expect the combined effect of
moving the policy rate to a more neutral
level and commencing balance sheet
reduction
um to uh to to have the effect of
bringing inflation down
uh seeing some moderation uh in demand
while the supply side catches up a bit
and then i think by moving expeditiously
towards a more neutral posture it
provides the committee with optionality
in either direction
and so that'll give me as the ability um
to monitor a set of indicators uh very
importantly of course inflation and
employment also inflation
expectations
um as well as how the labor market is
responding
and that'll provide a sense of
how
the uh policy rate um
might evolve beyond that point um
depending on uh how much progress we're
seeing in particular on inflation and
how well the labor market is holding up
so governor brainard what is the goal of
fed policy right now i hear some people
who say that if
what's driving inflation is a disruptive
supply chain
or
insufficient supplies of oil or computer
chips or housing in city centers how
will higher interest rates
address those problems that we're seeing
what is what is the goal of what the fed
is trying to do right now
well i think the
goal uh is very uh straightforward um
we're committed to bringing inflation
down to two percent over time
while continuing
to sustain the recovery
and you're right that
the
very high inflation we're seeing right
now
is the result of
a series of inflationary shocks
associated both with the pandemic
the omicron and delta variants and most
recently uh with russia's invasion of
ukraine and those are those are supply
shocks um what the
federal reserve's tools um are well
suited for
is helping to bring demand into balance
um with supply over time
and so there i think the kinds of uh
tightening and financial conditions that
we've talked about
um not just what you see in the federal
funds rate um but that broader set
whether it be um the two percentage
point increases in mortgages whether it
be the increase in the cost of credit
for businesses
those broader set of financial
conditions will help to moderate
demand particularly in
areas where demand has been
extremely hot
durable goods for instance um and you
know fiscal
is also going to be a drag this year
the global
economy looks to be slowing more broadly
that'll also
spill over into the u.s all of those
things
should along with our
plans
on monetary policy bring
demand
into better balance with supply and
alleviate that very high inflation that
you've been seeing
so you said over time that inflation
should come down to two percent over how
long do you think it will take
inflation to come back to two percent
yeah so i'm very wary of making
predictions i think we all should be um
we have most recently seen um
a
geopolitical
shock from um
russia's invasion of ukraine
i don't think that was in my inflation
outlook a year ago it certainly wasn't
um omicron and delta were surprises even
to many public health experts certainly
also hard to predict those kinds of
shocks so i think we're in
a period of very high uncertainty i
think it's really important to emphasize
that
so i'm going to be very cautious about
making predictions
but i am looking to the month to month
data
to get a sense of what's happening on
core
uh core inflation which is uh more
tightly connected um to demand
and there again i think we saw a
moderation uh this month
um in that core goods inflation where we
had been seeing outsized contributions
to inflation for some time
and it's those kinds of developments
that will give me confidence uh that we
are
going to be successful in achieving our
two percent uh goal
precisely how long that's going to take
i think it'd be very difficult to
estimate right now just given uh
uncertainty around russia ukraine
uncertainty around
china coveted and still uncertainty
around the pandemic
you noted there there's a long list of
unusual unprecedented uh you know choose
your adjective developments uh that the
global economy has come through
and so when people talk about achieving
a soft landing i wonder governor
brainerd are there any historical
analogies or antecedents that you could
point to
where the fed is facing something that
they attempted back in the past is this
more like the 1970s the 1950s are there
any analogies here that you think are
most relevant to either the present
circumstance or what it is the fed is
trying to achieve
well i certainly think um that it is
helpful um to think about a variety of
past cases
both
where
we saw hard landings and soft landings
to try to
inform our thinking about the
appropriate path of policy and what
indicators
i and my colleagues should be looking at
to gauge whether we're
seeing the kind of progress that we need
to see on inflation in particular but i
don't think there's one good
uh analogy in the sense that this is a
quite unique uh again set of
circumstances
uh
the combination of a pandemic
and a war i think is pretty unusual here
and of course
we go into these shocks with very well
anchored inflation expectations
um and as i look across the dashboard of
indicators on inflation expectations
longer term inflation expectations
remain well anchored that's enormously
important
and will be very helpful
to us
when i look at the strength uh in the
labor market
there too i see
a very high number of job openings um
and uh there i think there's
there's quite a bit of capacity for
labor demand to moderate among
businesses by actually reducing job
openings um without necessitating uh
high levels of layoffs for instance so i
think there's some unique features here
um that make this both very challenging
but also
are important in terms of my thinking
about
what policy path on both policy rate
hikes and balance sheet
runoff
will be
sufficient to get us
to the two percent goal
how should we weigh the restraint that
comes from
shrinking the fed's
asset portfolio versus raising the
short-term interest rate for for example
how much of an increase in long-term
rates do you model from the prospective
runoff
of those asset holdings
well
our jobs would be a lot easier if we had
a
precise estimate of that and it was a
robust
precise estimate just as would be true
um in our discussion earlier about
the full set of financial conditions
that constitute
neutral financial conditions but
um it certainly um
in
the case um in our in our approach um to
getting inflation down uh that the
balance sheet will play an important
role
uh in removing monetary policy
accommodation operating in the
background while the federal funds rate
serves as our primary active tool
the balance sheet runoff
will have and probably already the
expectation of it it probably does
already have important effects on
financial conditions
um and so together i think it's
important to recognize um that removing
policy accommodation through both tools
um has a as a greater
combined effect than either tool on its
own in terms of
estimates of
how great an increase in the federal
funds rate is equivalent to a given
amount of
runoff of the balance sheet there's a
range of estimates i've certainly
seen estimates um
you know that i think are widely you
know accepted in the literature that our
balance sheet run down could be worth
two to three additional rate hikes over
the entire course of the rundown but i
have to say any such estimates come with
really wide uh confidence intervals
um and so you know if you think about
how do you build a direct comparison
between the two tools it's really how
much of a reduction the balance sheet
would have an equivalent effect on
10-year treasury yields as an increase
in the federal funds rate of one-quarter
percentage point and we think of those
reductions of course
as as
permanent
increases
and so you know again a wide range of
estimates
in terms of precisely
what those would be i would not hang my
hat on any particular number
but it's very uh clear from all those
estimates
that the reduction in the balance sheet
will contribute to monetary policy
tightening
over the life of the runoff
and that that is
in addition to
the kind of tightening that we might see
through the policy rate
we're almost out of time but
before we finish our wsj survey of
economists this past week found
that our respondents estimated a 28
chance of a recession over the next year
how do you see the risks of a recession
over the next few years does 28 seem too
low
about right or too high
yeah
so look the u.s economy um enters
this
period of elevated uncertainty with a
very strong labor market and significant
underlying economic momentum
and
that i think
bodes well
for the ability to
bring inflation down while also
continuing to sustain the recovery
and
ensure that it's an inclusive recovery i
look at the same things everybody else
does i certainly remain attentive to the
shape of the yield curve and i'm well
aware of the historical significance
of inversions
but i think that there are different
parts of the yield curve that are
informative and certainly
um the
the forward part of the yield curve
really doesn't um uh signal uh anything
of concern there
um you know sort of a later part of the
yield curve um you know watching that
very carefully
but there are other um
data points inflation inflation
expectations uh the evolution of
activity
um that are going to be extremely
important as i gauge with the right pace
of removal of accommodation is
and again i think there are good reasons
um to think uh that we can bring
inflation down over time
seeing a moderation of demand while the
supply side continues to recover
and we continue to see
a strength in the labor market
well on that bright note we are out of
time
thank you again governor brainerd for
joining us today well thank you nick
it's pleasure
and thank you to everyone who joined us
on twitter and on youtube
you